thanks to curiositystream for supporting
this episode
go to curiositystream.com microcosmos
to start streaming thousands of
documentaries and
non-fiction shows
in the year 1675 i discovered
very small living creatures in rainwater
which had stood
but few days in a new earthen pot
glazed blue within
those are the famous words that anthony
van leeuwenhoek used
to describe microbes though he didn't
use the word microbe he called them
animolecules and the letter itself is
not exactly the one he wrote
leeuwenhoek's version was written
of course in dutch and then sent off to
henry oldenburg
the secretary of the royal society in
london who founded the publication
philosophical transactions
oldenburg translated laevenhook's work
into english
and published it in 1677 the rest
as they say is microbiology
in 1932 the scientist clifford dobell
published a biography of leyvanuk called
anthony von leavenhook
and his little animals devel introduced
his subject with some self-consciousness
for taking on the story of someone who
if you've been interested in microscopy
you have almost certainly heard of
and he wrote dear reader i know full
well
that you and everyone else must have met
mr van leeuwenhoek many a time before
but please
let me reintroduce him to you for he is
a man
worth knowing more intimately though he
was born exactly 300 years ago
he is still very much alive and would be
glad
to make you a better acquaintance
provided only that you are
quote a true lover of learning as of
course
you are the fascination with lee
hook's work for dobell and so many of us
lies
in the scope of leeuwenhoek's curiosity
and the writing that documented many of
his journeys
into the microcosmos
[Music]
born in the netherlands in 1632
leeuwenhoek was a draper by trade
meaning that he sold
cloth he took up microscopy as a hobby
learning to grind lenses and turn them
into a tool to see into tiny worlds
the simple microscopes he built were
better than many of those of his
contemporaries producing images
that were both more magnified and more
clear
though of course compared with what the
average high school biology class has
today
they were very bad at both of those
things
the creatures leeuwenhoek described in
his 1677 publication
were not his first description of tiny
animals in water though
in 1674 he wrote of green streaks
spirally wound a description that later
observers have taken to refer to the
filamentous green algae
spirogyra he also wrote of little
creatures he'd found that were
as he described them a thousand times
smaller
than the smallest ones i have ever yet
seen
upon the rind of cheese those little
cheese rind creatures he was describing
were
likely mites
[Music]
reading leeuwenhoek's work it's kind of
like following an old treasure map
his words lay out pathways and clues
that help us
navigate through a drop of 17th century
water
and if you follow that map at the end
you find a wealth of information
the knowledge of microbes and their
identities that was still
unknown in his time but that in the
centuries since
has been accumulated
for dobelle leyvanov's 20th century
scientist biographer
this treasure hunt was a long one born
out of his own enchantment with these
original discoveries and a desire
to better understand them he learned
dutch only to find that the 17th century
dutch of lehnoke's letters
was impenetrable to him and with world
war one raging around him
he had to set aside his attempts to
translate leifenhoek's work for some
time
but eventually through what seems to be
largely a lot of determination
dobel was able to work his way through
leeuwenhoek's letters and that labor of
love led
naturally to translating things like
leeuwenhoek's descriptions of
his own poop per dobel leeuwenhoek wrote
the following
i have usually of a morning a
well-formed stool
but hitherto i have had sometimes a
looseness of the bowels
my excrement being so thin i was at
diverse times
constrained to examine it but levenhook
wasn't documenting his tool just
for the sake of it in that sample he saw
an opportunity to observe
the animals within i have at times
seen very prettily moving antimolecules
their bodies were somewhat longer than
broad
and their belly which was flattened
provided with several
feet with which they made such a
movement through
the clear medium and the globules that
we might fancy we saw
a piece of bed running up against a wall
that description sounds
promising but dobel had a problem
leeuwenhoek
had compared his microbes to a pissabet
and like you and i
dobel had no idea what a pisa bed was
even the original english translation
he'd read shrugged it off as a dutch
term with no
obvious english equivalent dobel had to
find a 17th century dutch english
dictionary to figure out that a pissabed
is a woodlaws and with that reference
point
dobel had enough to diagnose levenhook
very belatedly of course
with giardia the product of a flagellate
known as giardia intestinalis
at the time lavenhuk was identifying the
microbial residence of his stool
he almost certainly didn't know their
role in his poor digestion
nor did he of course have any name for
them or any of the other microbes that
we now know he saw
and yet we can identify rotifers from
his characterization of their wheeled
heads
and vorticella from his description of
their belled bodies
the irony of our century's later
fascination with reconstructing and
replicating leefenhook's work
is that his contemporaries had a much
harder time of it
lavenhook didn't help his cause much
refusing to provide extensive details of
his methods
and even keeping his microscope building
techniques to himself
he did however provide eight signed
testimonies from various men
including a minister to verify that he
had made
these observations of course signed
testimony is one thing
reproducibility is another several of
leenhook's contemporaries tried and
failed
to replicate his observations until
finally robert hook
the famed microscopist and writer slash
illustrator of micrograffia
was able to see the tiny antimolecules
levenhook had seen
hook however was willing to outline his
specific methods
and demonstrate them validating the
observations levenhook had
made and providing others with the means
to make their own microbial ventures
and like dobel centuries later hook was
reportedly so
taken with leenhook's work that he
learned dutch to read his letters
the legacy of leeuwenhoek is in the
microbes he uncovered
but of course it was more than that it
was also the curiosity that he passed on
and the acts of interpretation that they
inspired both
literally with all of these scientists
taking up dutch to just learn from his
letters
and then scientifically as we decipher
what microbes
he must have seen and so it seems
fitting to close
with how leeuwenhoek viewed his own
little antimolecules
he said among all the marvels that i
have discovered in nature
these are the most marvelous of all
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us
this episode was brought to you by
curiositystream
a subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction tv shows
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including award-winning exclusives and
originals
that cover topics like history nature
science food technology
travel and more you can check out things
like
super sea slugs where you'll get an up
close and personal look at nudibranchs
with their weaponized stinging cells
sulfuric acid spraying and i mean just
look at them
they look very good they look like that
who wouldn't want to watch them
you can stream curiosity streams library
including their
collection of curated programs
hand-picked by their experts
to any device for viewing anytime
anywhere
and if you go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos
and use the code microcosmos to sign up
it will only cost you
14.99 for an entire year
we also of course need to thank today
and also every other day
our patrons on patreon you're seeing
some of their names on the screen right
now and without them
this show could not exist so if you like
the show and you want to help us
continue making it
you can join all of those amazing people
at patreon.com
journey2micro if you'd like to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can follow him at jam and
germs on instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you